[Applause]
timing son of a [ __ ] this is my show I
do the champ comes to my show he told me
he was too busy to come and now he's
coming on your [ __ ] dick operation
here
a king of MMA
[Music]
look how he's backing down
I'm ready I'm ready
[ __ ] his ass Craig tell me what to do
tell me what to do I'm in a leg lock
Look Who's acting up now
what's up brother you guys watch the
ratings
you're no longer needed
folk I'm out here taking bullets for you
no I'm out here [ __ ] fighting the
fight for you
they're trying to screw you say yeah
they're trying to screw you voke they're
trying to screw this man out of it what
happened did he talk to you did you see
it he said it's not signed yet they're
trying to screw you Vogue why they're
trying to tell them they'll get all
company man on us now
he's trying to burn the [ __ ] house
I saw UFC security out there the guy was
sweating his balls off he's like hey
people are afraid we've got an intruder
here
afraid of you what book I've been
working out yeah
[ __ ] not bad right why does it you
look at the energy as well
where's the stream
all the haters it was a lot of a lot of
hips you were mostly humping at fellas
yeah I was trying to get out some
aggressions
for my arms
wow it's a nice little setup you have
here for a third raid podcast listen
we're trying to do our best we're trying
to do our best okay this is not the MMA
hour but we're trying to do our [ __ ]
spokesman on he cooked wings with me did
he really heckies Takis Takis Takis do
you do you copy your cops here for that
all the time all the time because
they'll say that it's Australian ah yeah
even the Mexican fans get upset I
actually legit never heard of them he
did wings with
you crumb up all the you do that with
all chips like what do you call them you
just call them do you create the
breading out of the cheese yes you
crumble it up and then you use that as a
as like a crumb whether you want to do
chicken tenders yeah salt vinegar chips
yeah you can do some Doritos if you
wanna we can wait I see you yeah have
you seen those videos
you're lying right now you've never seen
it I have yes of course it's great now
it's great I hope you know Ariel my wife
is in the food recipes like 20 times but
yeah he reckons
I have watched her YouTube videos oh 100
because my wife does a cooking channel
what doesn't want to have to do with the
other well I'm into the cooking world
that's like someone insulting a black
person be like I have a lot of black
friends how many black friends do you
have a lot Daniel Cormier best friend
did he really do that champ is sitting
right there yeah
you you could meet them I know that was
nice to you I want you to have
opportunities because they will come to
my show anymore these guys I reach out
to Adam I know [ __ ] because you dress
like you're in The Sandlot
I love Benny the Jets Rodriguez
so how are we guys well we couldn't make
it on the show you got to talk about
that man do we want to talk business or
no yes he doesn't want to talk about it
bring in Joe you don't know Lopez
his last name is Lopez that guy yeah
yeah Lopez yeah what is wrong with that
by the way Hispanic he's from Spanish
yeah oh Spain for sure but that that is
like Austin white guys yeah
by the way do you guys notice everyone
always talks about vocal success they
always mention ckb as they should but I
always mention Joe as well you do you do
Joe deserves yeah freestyle Freestyle
Fighting yes brought out some nice come
on
correct what do you know about that
correct Dove knows about the dillas
the credit that he deserves took me like
now everyone obviously knows I'm from
Freestyle Fighting gym and all that type
of stuff but obviously the ckb of them
was like you know like it's I think it's
a story and all that but everybody knows
I'm based in Australia I'm at freestyle
now but you're right A lot of people
would push that narrative officer oh you
got his back you've got to go back to
dude now and I know that I have his what
do you mean now
whoa there was beef
this guy salt of the earth he will wake
up at one time volcano you know he lives
in Australia yeah my show different time
zone one time you came on from the
hospital his daughter was having surgery
yeah
this guy wouldn't cancel on me he did it
from the waiting room I was like wow you
could have canceled
the surgeon
down time they got some work worried
he's stressed out this is what I say
evoke GSP Izzy Frankie Edgar certain
guys who didn't change when they became
Champions he's at the topic is that
Mensch Mitch
[Laughter]
you know I've never put a cigarette to
my lips in my life really I never
actually touched my but no I can't do
that I can't you think I'm breaking it
right now I think right now we could
make [ __ ] history I can't do it right
I've got a cigar
where's the cigar right there we got
cigars there you put your mouth on that
that's the difference
bro no coven on here look at this what
is this is this good oh it's actually
trying to get me no come on man would
you think I'll do that to you do you
think that was yours no what am I
supposed no idea about it but I wouldn't
let you do it
if something's up iron in on it hold on
this is a [ __ ] crazy like that fire I
know what am I doing outer end
I was like I can't believe Vogue wasted
his day to come over here there's
literally five people watching it was
crazy Chad are you gonna take this
slander from the second greatest
journalist of all the love I'm getting
it number two Mani is here I don't see
my name anywhere I'm gonna pretend like
I do no uh why is Ariel there all right
what do I do yeah you suck in you suck
in oh yeah you bump off right is it a
bump off you're trying to get me sick
I'm being serious oh no you don't impale
don't even have a bump off you know bump
off what do you call it oh my God is
that where Joseph
[Laughter]
yeah
he has to say yes okay I'm paying him
yes
[Laughter]
he's too handsome for that he's behind
the Kelly he is look at this handsome
guy get over here dude
[Applause]
he's gotta get all nervous now as well
don't you don't have to talk or anything
like that now Craig be honest was this
the guy you were chasing through the
streets of Australia
like that very similar yeah really just
like that do you speak English yeah is
it okay I don't know
just beautiful dude look at those
reviews can you can you put an airpod in
there I'm paying the van I'm paying the
man get back behind the camera
all right sorry
yeah being hot because he's married he
can't take it you let him get into the
DMS what's that do you let him get into
the DMS oh look at
and then he emails
I do my like social media you handle it
yeah like some of them like we'll post
things if I have to do it here and there
but I like I I try and get back to
people okay uh how do you feel about PF
Changs are you a fan
[Applause]
we love you Brendan have you ever done
truck stop Diaries what is it food truck
Diaries
don't do it you'll have the runs they'll
give you some kitties like orange
chicken I have done it I haven't you
have done it yeah and you had a good
time no wonder they're trying to screw
you I did it I did it when I did you as
well women hold on hold on hold on why
are you saying they're trying to scream
you think this is real I think they're
trying to put the screws you remember 25
years ago Montrell screwdrop Bret Hart
no you don't you're not a wrestling fan
someone has to be a wrestling fan here
no no no because we got [ __ ] in high
school
it was a little different like we were
[ __ ] girls
they're trying to put the screws on this
man okay I'm not going to stand for it
folks yeah you got it back I'll get it
again I'm gonna fly down to Las Vegas
open the doors of the HQ Hunter Dana we
need to have a chat oh this man flew how
far is that flight to Abu Dhabi 15 know
15 hours just to be the backup show me
one show me one pound for pound grade in
this place I ain't gonna stop till I get
it in Perth yeah that's what I'm talking
about I love Izzy I love Izzy he's not
doing that hey he's not being backup
fighter why are you gonna let him divide
and conquer bro what are you trying to
do here I'm trying to say he is a rare
breed don't do that this man is so
serious
they should be they should be bending
over for you and saying please Alex
whatever you want you want two title
fights on that night I'll give you two
title fights you're gonna get it Alex
I'm a company man
[Music]
he's being screwed company man it's a
whole thing yeah look at that necklace I
I I ain't being screwed I'll rip that on
that neck right now you want some is it
an octagon yeah it is they gave it to
you no I got it done all right
Alexander the Great in the Octagon yeah
you know I'm a dog you know the great at
45 and soon to be finished
except for me remember this what's that
no one's picking you in that fight hold
on I'm picking him only because he's
here
oh Islam you're so great I love you bro
I mean yeah he's a big guy did you grow
that beard to prepare him for it I'm
gonna trim them
if I trim the mustache you know it's
done 100 you have to do that
I know we were just talking about but we
were doing the bump off that's right
what is it called bump off but you don't
know what that is because you don't
watch enough fun porn no you've never
seen S as dude I don't know what you're
talking about come on
ask to ask you've never seen when both
guys pull guard and they just put a
little something in between yeah you're
not sure of course yes of course of
course I thought you were talking about
Jujitsu we are talking about Jiu Jitsu
which is your favorite type of Jitsu
that's right
we're cooking
Hawaii yes you trying to take me out no
okay because I only go you have to say
yeah yeah no because no no no you were
running late I know I am but I need you
to stay a little bit longer because we
have to kick these guys out wow because
we have another we have another guest
that's coming in you need me to listen
you're the second greatest MMA
journalist of all time which is pretty
good like think about look at the energy
you brought when you came in this room
I'm a little jealous you got VOC you got
Leon I couldn't get them in studio this
week no no I'm better but but what you
what you'll uh they like to slag on me
they like to make fun but no The Outfits
all rooted in jealousy they know they
can never look this good yeah I mean you
know what I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
before you guys get out of here is there
any final words that you'd like to say
to helwani this is very foul would you
like to say to myself is there any final
words you like to say to Islam
I think is how do you always get it
wrong how do you say it
in the H is
forget about that you want to make
headlines have him say a message to the
Brass who are trying to put the screws I
feel like that's headlines for you more
a different way oh let's see oh with
what Knockouts yeah yeah
never mind
stay tuned
for my YouTube channel
are you sitting on something hey do we
have some good information
subscribe to my YouTube channel
okay how do we get it out this is good
how do we get it out all right listen I
I'm actually very much in favor of the
fighters breaking their own news are we
going to do good not bad cop no well I
mean you're in the UFC's pocket we know
that yeah yeah I know I know big pockets
okay let's do good cop bad cop okay do
you want to be good copper I'll be good
cop I'm Pro fighter all the time okay so
you go you go no that's it I I think he
should break the news on his YouTube
channel like you did that you were the
backup fighter what news well you got
news I could tell you got news
you're dropping a video tonight it's
going to be huge that's how you become a
Salesman Vogue yeah you're right you
know you're under something you can only
lead a horse to water right Volk is
you're one of the worst Liars I've ever
am I doing that on purpose oh
oh he could be playing you I'm playing
everyone the [ __ ] up yeah I'm telling
them 4D tests let me tell you something
if I see on February 12th or is it
February 13th over there whatever it is
that date yeah you're fighting anyone
not name Islam
like in the feather way you wouldn't
like who would excite him I would be
this is the worst thing a parent can say
to a child I would be disappointed in
you disappointed please I'll be
disappointing myself if it wasn't
so I'm gonna make it happen right yeah
subscribe to my YouTube channel this guy
is a wild [ __ ] boy okay listen
cooking book make sure you get it Craig
where are we sending them to my only
fans yeah
let's go what's going on there the Bumbo
like that one now I've seen the Jersey I
think it's really funny but uh okay but
the only fans has Jiu Jitsu stuff but
does it does it have anything else
that's kind of you can't get Hulk shots
if the Press is right really well you're
so [ __ ] rude
will you show dick I mean again if the
price is right I think we all have a
price
what's the point about this phone hold
on what's this did you know about his
only fans everybody
this was uh this was like a ultimate
fight at times wasn't it it was a while
ago I was forced to actually create an
early fans because I just started
selling the rash guards and I was like
you know what they might sue me because
I didn't get permission but if I haven't
only they can't do [ __ ] it's marketing
wow it's a clever man that is smart yes
that is good good money off that made it
be yeah good for you are you showing so
what million dollars dick comes out
sadly a little less
100 000.
a hundred dollars
yeah we're live right now you want to
make some headlines literally
okay guys thank you so much for being
here you have to stay here anywhere yeah
you guys are we gonna go uh thank you so
much bro
that's fine that's fine thank you
brother thank you so much
all the best I'll subscribe to the only
fans
all right see you later wow look at this
can you go all right guys we gotta take
a break for a second because it's time
to get healthy okay we're gonna get a
healthy the quick and easy way with one
delicious scoop of athletic greens one
AG one right here you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help start your day right
okay this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all the things
literally okay age one is a small micro
habit with massive benefits you're going
to be sleeping better the quality is
going to be so improved of your recovery
specifically the mental Clarity and
alertness you're going to get and it
costs you less than three dollars a day
you're investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit think
about that right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com flagrant again that
is athleticgreens.com flagrant to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional assurance
now let's get back to the show please
listen you came in with Reckless abandon
it was absolutely uh it was a good thing
it was amazing I did like eight push-ups
I haven't done eight push-ups you did
six but it's okay fair enough
you are
uncontrollable bro nobody can [ __ ]
control you listen they don't call me
hilwani for nothing that's true 12
straight uh journalists of the Year
Awards who's counting no big deal yeah
uh the most feared man in the game truly
the king of all media forget about it I
mean just keeping a media period
Jake Paul I was there in the ring a
couple weeks ago and no big deal show
times can we just
it's hard to go from in your studio yeah
behind the camera to live oh it's easy
running the show see if your name's area
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about my boy no nurse
whatsoever HBO Real Sports you know you
want me to be the uh professional
journalist guy I'll be the professional
journalist guy it's that easy that is
daddy that's like Swiss army knife is
there anything you can't do um I don't
think so you know I did NBA for ESPN of
course everyone remembers those games
Christmas a couple of years in a row uh
E60 outside the line Sports Center I
mean the list goes on did you play
sports
the Jewish Olympics are you familiar two
years in a row pet don't laugh I was
capped into the basketball why do they
have to make a Jewish
why is its own classification yeah yeah
hold on why do you guys have your own
happiness Jews can be in it the regular
yeah you know as you guys know sometimes
what are the what are the effects like
what do you guys everything it's like a
legit Olympic game accounting or like
debate
basketball allergies
baseball soccer right right I was
Captain two years in a row no yes
really yeah but I wasn't um can I say
one thing you went to Syracuse that's a
company man move not at all absolutely
you want to work for the company you go
to Syracuse if you want to be a
journalist in the United States of
America you go to Syria Canadian so I
was trying to live the American
Dreams of the greats like Marv Albert
this is true uh Bob Costas Mike Tirico
but can you name the school what I
forgot the name of it but there's a
specific Google ads new house yeah I
went to it yeah right that's why I'm
asking
whatever you were a Maga yeah yeah you
were a Maga
but it's actually funny because going to
Syracuse is the reason why I pivoted to
combat journalism because when I got
there everyone wanted to be the same
thing yeah everyone wanted to be the
next hostas Marvel yeah sticking I was
like
the support UFC this this organization
is only eight years old let me go in
this Direction let me try to be the
Howard Cosell of MMA yeah not quite
there yet were you a huge fan coming up
into okay so you're already a huge fan I
order all the pay-per-views I didn't
have any friends I would order them in
my dorm by myself they used to be on
Friday nights back in the day that's how
far back I go Wrestling Boxing I loved
it all yeah yeah here I am just running
the game I like having other French
Canadians on here man are you French
Canadian of course you got something on
your lip my boy no no okay so which part
my parents are from uh from Quebec City
wow yeah but you're not born there no I
was born in Paris but my mom's from
Laval your mom's from Laveau that was
the hood though yeah yeah a little bit
whoa she's English Canadian but my dad's
French Canadian through and through wow
yeah it's not that good it'll be honest
yeah yeah but you speak quebecois yeah
of course so you don't speak French
either okay this is perfect yeah that
was great in school 50 of the day has to
be French but it's not French well yes
it's the French Canadian yeah you're
trying in French
it's like the Taekwondo of languages
yeah it's like uh people from France
hate why do you think that is it's very
broken it's anglicized as they say it's
not very um it's not as classy ooh it's
probably how people from England view
people don't do this don't do that no
not Americans I just mean like people
who have like all American accents are
how English should be spoken yep uh All
American accents yeah I heard now I just
became an American citizen I heard that
they uh oh yes
for the first time yeah it actually felt
really good and why did you vote for
Kanye well I felt as though his views
were very sort of uh inclusive oh you
can storm the capital now this is
awesome yes you're locked dude but what
I wanted to say was yeah when you do the
test yeah yeah the citizenship tests
they ask you questions what do they ask
you so so there's a hundred questions to
choose from you only have to get six out
of 10 right but then you have to write a
sentence and then you have to answer
sort of uh English speaking questions so
what they do is they play a movie for
you and then you have to recite some of
the lines from the movie yeah you know a
movie I got what it was [ __ ] tough
because I couldn't understand a word
that they were saying go Unchained no uh
imagine having a recite yeah
it was a great movie but the dialogue
was very complex it was hard to
uh what's that one with the guy the big
guy uh he's never seen a movie I've
never seen him Green Mile oh Gringo
puppy
puppy it was so hard to understand why
do you cause divisions
why doesn't the UFC like me we get it we
understand right now why in English just
not English a bowling ball whatever has
to say it's not English is this in a
language yeah it's like but I heard you
have a special coming out yeah yeah
don't you do you what are you gonna try
to say
but I heard you were I heard you're
getting into stand up I heard undc are
going to do like a comedy do it I mean
we would kill it you honestly would kill
it is that the thing to do all joking
aside it made me really happy to see you
guys oh thank you it was nice I did text
you did I not did it was very nice of me
well first you texted me how to get DC
on the show it was it was very sorry can
I be honest I didn't even watch you guys
you probably saw a [ __ ] tweet yeah
look did you is he coming no he's not
coming did they say no or did they know
I didn't reach out through the uh
through the woman because you wanted
DC's personal number yeah I think I am I
mean just who do you think I am
[Laughter]
she didn't try no a little disappointed
well then I tried to go through the UFC
and then I was going to go through that
woman and then I don't know we had a we
have a lot of great guys but I love DC
and I think you guys have unbelievable
chemistry and uh yeah you guys yeah I
told you this and I'll say it again it's
the only thing on Zoom regularly that I
would watch and feel like you guys were
in the room together that's very nice
yeah and it was we go together like a
plate of brown rice and orange chicken
foreign
[Laughter]
why don't we do uh competing stand up
you in in shop yeah you said it here
first no I'm just throwing it out there
you do rose battle you would try to do a
rose battle this is actually great do
you think I this this would be like Hulk
Hogan in his prime okay competing on
Maple Leaf wrestling on a Saturday
morning against like jobber a oh you're
talking about the Virgin stuff again
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]